minha vitamina B12 está em 1450 é sinal
de inflamação bem a B12 Todos nós
sabemos é um nutriente essencial pro
corpo é uma vitamina no complexo B mas
os seus níveis não estão diretamente
relacionados à inflamação então o nível
de vitamina B12 14450 pic GR por ml está
dentro do intervalo normal que
geralmente varia nos Laboratórios de 200
a 900 só que isso pode variar Ok então
tem que checar as referências de cada
laboratório e a inflamação no corpo é
normalmente mais medida Através de
outros indicadores a proteína ser
reativa o VHS que é velocidade de
sedimentação de eritrócitos E além disso
tem outros marcadores aí menos comuns o
tnf alfa eter leucina 6 né em casos aí
específicos podem ser sol estados também
a B12 elevada para quem não tá fazendo
suplementação tem que ser investigado
com muito carinho muita atenção e
cuidado porque pode ser uma das doenças
crônicas que eu vou mencionar agora por
exemplo pode ser uma das condições
hepáticas que aumentam a B12 são tumores
hepáticos carcinoma hepatocelular
hepatopatia alcoólica esteatose hepática
não alcoólica e a cirrose e algumas
doenças hematológicas alguns cânceres de
sangue a leucemia a policitemia Vera a
doença de hodkin doenças
mieloproliferativas em modo geral e
também tem algumas doenças autoimunes
que aumentam B2 a tiroidite rimoto por
exemplo a doença celíaca artrite
reumatóide lupos eritematoso sistêmico
então é importante você procurar o
médico e fazer essa investigação Ok para
saber se a B 12 alta é alguma coisa para
se preocupar ou não